that leapfrogs a bit over some other
players
he now reaches fifty percent with three
and a half out of seven certainly
a much better standing on the tournament
uh
format daniel dak he is on three points
trying i think to hold on to that end
game against constantinoplesco
his countryman but speaking of the man
of the hour let's take a look
at what levon aronian has to say about
his game he is with our friend christian
carrillo
thank you alejandro yes i'm with a very
happy levon aronian after a
vicious victory levon how does it feel
to bounce back after yesterday's
accident
oh yeah feels great especially
when you know you get
such an easy game you don't get such a
music game
in in such a strong tournament
absolutely and
tell us a little bit about yesterday
what happened yesterday did you forget
the theory or uh
did you just hurry yeah i knew
that this is a throwish line and
i knew it very well but i started
inventing new ways to play for black
which is not a very good idea yeah
so yeah instead of bishop d7 i knew that
both coin b6 and b5
are sufficient for a draw and i drew
like that
zillion times and then blitz game but
just like a great fighter you bounced
back
and you came and uh were victorious
today take us through the game
okay uh i thought that uh
alexander will play uh
queen's gambit but uh c5 of course now
is
super solid cdcd i thought this is what
he had in mind or something play this
with white pieces
yeah so i thought just to play something
uh
you know he might not expect this
and yeah dc a6 castle b5
distributor bishop b7 and of course
queen e2 is the main theoretical move
d5 is not a
particularly great move but i just
thought that
you know we'll get the something similar
similar to this quinn's gambit positions
but it's important to uh
take advantage of sasha's desire to
think
yeah generally it's if you want to beat
krishuk you
you have to lure him in time trouble
because he's uh
he's very good uh without time travel
are you ever concerned that
luring him into time trouble is actually
a disadvantage
no he's very good in in time trouble but
this would be like you know very good in
in blindfold just
you can be good but not going to be as
good
as a normal uh for sure yeah and was
this d5 prepared uh
from something home or in your arsenal
i just looked at it a couple of days ago
it's uh i'm not particularly proud
but it has its points at some points
yeah bishop d6 of course is the way to
equalize
at this point yeah and you have to play
four he takes takes
queen c7 or castle and black has a very
solid position
where do you feel like he lost control
after bishop b7 it looks very pleasant
for me because now i get my bishop on f4
rookie one
and yeah i thought this rook e8 was very
clever
but in fact i have this knight c7 elmira
told me
and bishop g3 yeah i completely missed
this bishop g3
which is of course a shame but knight
seven knight h5
and bishop g3 yeah that's very beautiful
it is enough if you take now you take on
uh
and yeah this looks uh this looks like a
big advantage for white but anyway i
feel that quindy 2 is extremely
unpleasant for black to play here
because there is this
time factor as well so bishop c5 was
correct because now bishop seven queen
c8 is not that easy
like so i thought bishop g5 bishop b7
yeah h4 is a bit maybe it's a bit too
much but i thought it's uh i think it's
a way to play
the point is that knight d5 i wanted to
take uh bishop g5
takes on knight g5 i thought that this
is kind of interesting because 95 rookie
1
and 97 i thought doesn't work for some
reason rookie one
also somehow it feels like it's not a
practical move you don't feel like
putting the
knight just without yeah yeah i kind of
missed this i thought that i have this
play with bishop d1 but he just takes on
d5
ah yeah yeah doesn't feel natural though
yeah yeah no h6 looked like a regular
normal move and then uh takes and then
uh queen f4 yeah i thought i'm slightly
better
i'm kind of surprised that computer
thinks that there's nothing for me
yeah maybe it takes too long to bring my
bishop back here
also we should not trust this computer
it's uh
yeah this this is a good move this is a
good move he he definitely needs to get
rid of this
uh yeah
and this is probably fine because
he gets uh now i was thinking rookie
seven actually that i can play bishop d6
but then
turns out that he takes in queen g4 yeah
this move uh
i underestimate it queen f6 rook is six
queen effect when g7
yeah well uh see that the time factor
worked
in my favor time factor also the
weakness of the king
with only five minutes on the clock even
psychologically it feels very difficult
to play this type of positions with
black
yeah yeah of course because the
if every decision can be
fatal and you don't have an engine
before you to know that it's 0-0
obviously what does this victory do for
your morale and energy level
going into the last two games well
uh of course after yesterday's
play i was very angry at myself so it's
good to
get back some of the confidence and
come back to 50 i mean this is a
tough tournament very tough at some
point i was thinking that
it's very normal in such tournament to
have old roles
yesterday i lost and today at least they
came back so
i'm showing some fighting spirit
absolutely
levon always a pleasure to see to see
you in top shape
thank you back to you thank you uh
christian and congratulations very very
nice game
by lavon and he made it very clear
i'm playing sasha grishok i've got to
give him a position where he's going to
think a lot
and then i'm going to do my best to take
advantage of his time trouble
it worked like a charm not everybody
has the keys to the city of uh
of unlocking the secrets of
i really think that even if you get it
in time trouble it's it's not easy
starts yeah it's not a layup um
what is happening in the game of fabby
still two pawns down
down he has provoked rook b8 uh
the passivity of the rook is it's
well it's two pawns we need to find a
winning plan for black
it feels like all of black's pieces are
just preventing whites from doing
something
i'm interested in e6 yeah i understand
if my king was on c7
game over i'd just be able to develop my
rook rook f8 or rook
h8 double the rooks on the